saturday is going to be Donald Trump's
hundredth day in office and at this
point I consider the theme of the Donald
Trump presidency so far to be failure
they're still just a ton of government
positions that he hasn't filled just
people that have not been hired that
need to be hired
he obviously promised to drain the swamp
to say the very least he's done quite
the opposite and many of the positions
that he has filled have been filled by
lobbyists and wall street billionaires
multiple appointees and staffers have
been caught lying about Russia one of
whom ended up resigning in shame as a
result of it some of his closest
advisers don't seem to really like each
other and it's causing problems
internally Mexico is obviously not going
to pay for the wall his uh immigration
ban his immigration muslim-majority
country ban call it what you want has
been struck down not once but twice his
attempts to replace Obamacare have been
not only unsuccessful but universally
unpopular thus far the military strikes
have been an abortive disaster I could
keep going
not much winning to put it lightly and
as of yesterday Donald Trump has had yet
another failure under his belt Trump has
been trying to withhold funding from
sanctuary cities and I talked about this
a few weeks ago or at this point I guess
it's been a couple of months one of the
problems with the sanctuary city order
from Trump other than it's obvious
insanity is that there's no formal
definition of what a sanctuary city even
is generally we're talking about cities
that don't cooperate with ice and allow
undocumented immigrants to live in peace
within their communities but there's no
actual formal legal definition of what a
sanctuary city is and on Tuesday a
federal judge in San Francisco you
probably know where I'm going with this
declared that this move by the Trump
administration a aggressive move is
illegal unconstitutional in fact the
city of San Francisco and neighboring
Santa Clara County both so-called
sanctuary cities for undocumented
immigrants
sued the federal government after
Trump's executive order of January 25
and US District Court Judge William
auric ruled in favor of these two cases
the two cases are San Francisco V Trump
and Santa Clara V Trump and for the time
being the decision prevents the White
House from withholding money from any
sanctuary cities it doesn't only apply
as of as of today to San Francisco and
Santa Clara County it actually applies
to New York City it applies to Los
Angeles and Chicago and dozens of cities
around the country this is a total and
complete shutdown to borrow a phrase
from Donald Trump of Donald Trump's
order on sanctuary cities and the judge
determined that what Trump is attempting
to do with that executive order violates
both the 5th and 10th amendments to the
Constitution of the United States and
that Donald Trump is effectively trying
to do something that only Congress
actually has the power to do White House
chief of staff
Reince Priebus says that the decision
will be appealed and he thinks that the
matter will go to the Supreme Court
Donald Trump sort of expressing similar
sentiment on Twitter saying quote the
first sorry first the Ninth Circuit
rules against the ban referring to the
immigration ban and now it hits again on
sanctuary cities both ridiculous rulings
see you in the Supreme Court it's not
totally clear actually that this will go
to the Supreme Court it may but with a
lot of what Trump is doing it's so far
outside of anything that we that would
be supported by legal precedent the
Supreme Court doesn't have to take up
cases right the Supreme Court is
actually incredibly selective in the
cases that it takes up and there there's
no guarantee whatsoever that the Supreme
Court would look at this case if it got
to that point and say well we think that
there's really something to look at here
if it's very open and shut in Donald
Trump's
opposition in other words not in Trump's
favor the Supreme Court may well say no
we're not going to get involved in this
and if you're Trump if
if your Trump and the justice system
keeps saying what you're doing isn't
okay what you're doing is
unconstitutional what you're doing
violates the law what you're doing has
no precedent instead of just blaming
everybody else in this case judges and
courts maybe you should reflect on what
you're doing but I know that that's
obviously a completely fantasy world
thinking when it comes to Donald Trump
and his administration and the sanctuary
city order and that type of order right
not specifically Trump's order which now
has been suspended but that type of
order it causes immigrants to live in
fear statistics have shown a very
overwhelmingly that undocumented
immigrants are less likely to call 911
emergency when it's possible that their
immigration status will be questioned
merely because they call 911 Gration
crackdown attempts by the white house
are just going to exacerbate this and
this is a problem and it's bad for
everybody another example of hypocrisy
by the way when it comes to Republicans
in states rights or even more local
rights as the case may be
states rights local rights get the
federal government out except when we as
the federal government want to tell
states and municipalities what to do
fortunately if there's any silver lining
here it's that even in this absurd era
of a trump presidency and a
republican-controlled Congress there are
still some functioning checks and
balances which have seen judiciary's be
rational and humane in their influence
on the attempts made by the Trump
federal government to do all sorts of
terrible things fighting crime has been
the pretext from the Trump White House
the reason we need all this stuff is to
fight crime we did a very extensive
investigation into many of the
allegations that are often made about
undocumented immigrants and as it turns
out non citizen immigrants both
documented and undocumented commit crime
at a lower rate than your average
American citizen and sanctuary cities
already turn over
individuals who are undocumented and
have committed serious crime so this is
again the theme of the Trump
administration solutions that don't work
to problems that don't exist Trump and
sessions say they just want to make the
country safer it's clear that they want
to deport individuals who other than
their immigration status pose no threat
have committed no crime and furthermore
pose no threat by and large to American
society